good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy monday hope
everyone had an amazing splendid and
just delightful weekend yeah did you i
did i just want to know if there's
something you need to tell us before we
jump into the episode
today's episode is brought to you by
better help it doesn't matter who you
are or what you have life can be pretty
damn hard and without a healthy mind
it's even harder check out online
therapy with
betterhelp.comtoast and be on your way
to a little bit more ease thank you now
i feel ready to jump into this monday
thank you so much
mondays
just kind of like
so forgetful you know just monday
got a case of the monday blues
sorry though you don't seem like you do
no i'm
i had a great weekend thank you so much
for asking i went to my first
post-pandemic concert
that was your first one yeah oh brian
was like is this your first concert and
i had
to think about it but yeah right like
where else would you have one no no i
guess that's right how did it feel to be
back
in the music scene it was fabulous and i
just have to say like
i've been to music festivals before
and i went to global citizens festival
which is in central park and honestly it
was kind of
like amazing because
you really feel like you're at a music
festival like it's coachella it's on the
great lawn it's like this huge
thing and it's just like you really
forget you're in the city because you
can't hear anything like city noises
well if you watch new york by rick burns
they talk about the building of central
park and that was really something when
you're in the park you don't see any of
the city you don't see any of the
buildings like it seems as though the
bucolic nature goes on forever exactly
and i'm so glad that even 200 years
later that vibe is still being achieved
and it was just crazy because it really
felt like you know coachella it's so
remote and i just loved that i felt that
way and then i literally walked for two
minutes and got a cab like it was really
kind of the best of both worlds that
really sounds perfect i know and the
lineup was amazing and i had so many
thoughts first of all
camila cabello and sean mendes were both
there and they both performed and i did
miss camila cabello set because like i
didn't know homegirl was gonna be going
on so early and you know like the lineup
you get a later time the more famous you
are and like miss camila cabello was out
like during the sun like it was not
it was not a premium time slot for miss
camilla especially when shawn mendes
went like four hours later and i just
guess i never realized like in terms of
music like how much bigger he is than
her do you know what i mean i never
thought of it i wouldn't if you asked me
before this who's bigger i
i wouldn't know and i might say camilla
i mean there weren't really it doesn't
seem like there were small artists
there were smaller ones like who
like i don't know their names because i
just feel like when everybody's a large
artist like someone has to go earlier in
the day doesn't mean you're not you know
a big success shocking and then i
thought about most recently like i know
camila cabello went on a stadium tour
with taylor swift and was the opening
act
okay it was the opening act with taylor
swift and then i realized like shawn
mendes went on a taylor swift sized tour
like he did an arena stadium tour true
so the more i thought i just thought the
timing was very interesting and i know
like there are only so many slots but it
does me make a difference yeah you know
and she was out so early like it was
just shocking that's all i'll say she
was good though she was fine shawn
mendes was such a star like talk about
stage presence
rocker he's so handsome he gave
everything every ounce of him i was like
mesmerized he was incredible were you
there that time at robin hood that when
he performed no
i saw him perform at robin hood with
snitch and i understood i don't
understand and i could say like it
wasn't for me like i did feel like an
older woman there yeah of course
but i understood no i was really so
impressed with his stage presence his
music is so good like it was really
fabulous he had come out during
camilla's set you know did some charity
work for the early set and they sang
senorita together and that's their song
together right
okay cool so then i would say the best
performer of the night was hands down
lizzo like i've left her set feeling so
inspired she made everyone do like um
like manifestations like talk to
themselves like you are beautiful and i
was like so into it and you were
supposed to turn to the person next to
you tell them that they were beautiful
so me and brian were like you are
beautiful and her i wish she had more
time like there was just not enough time
for all of her jams and she played the
flute and she gave it 100
and she it was just it was everything i
would say that was my favorite
performance
then we need to talk about jlo
because jlo was really out here
giving me little to nothing like i don't
know and then when i think about the
timing of the lineup so the last two
performers were billy eilish in coldplay
okay and like jennifer lopez is like a
legend out here performing before billy
eilish and i just this is like a
conspiracy theory i came up with my head
i just feel like she like wasn't
like into it she ended with a new
original song that's coming in like some
movies she's a part of jackie the song
was incredible i do have to say like you
need to listen to it any song really
that's part of a movie soundtrack for
some reason the bar is just higher and
the songs are just better and if she
said like this is my new single for my
next album it would have been a flop but
it was very inspiring if it's from a
movie soundtrack you know it's good i do
think you will enjoy it i encourage you
to listen i'm sure that i will and then
she brought out ll cool j and uh
ja rule
um
so that was pretty cool and i just have
to say it made me actually have a lot of
respect for j lo because like i bet when
she like was put on those songs or like
ll cool j back in the day like agreed to
do one of her songs it was like a really
big deal and now both of them like we
know ja roll for fire festival and like
ella cool j like it's just
it's old news i would say but she really
just like keeps paying them respect like
constantly brings it back it was like a
huge festival like 60 000 people and i
thought that was very cool of jayla but
overall her performance was just like
kind of like giving me like low energy
and
she's been busy so maybe she's you know
oh she did like a whole like talk
session between songs about how like
she's in love and everyone's like
screaming that's crazy and then i saw
that ben was there and was he yeah i
thought he like helped her down from the
stage when she got off i saw that in a
headline oh okay i didn't see that but
so happy for them yeah really happy for
them i could imagine that you know it's
a bummer to go before billy eilish like
when you've done the super bowl no and
like you're just like a legend like a
living legend yeah i don't know maybe it
was a scheduling conflict but what was
so crazy this weekend there were so many
festivals going on and all the same
people were going to all the same
festivals megan the stallion literally
like she went from delaware to
governor's ball did you see her last
night no she wasn't there oh okay and
lizzo i think did all three yes so there
was firefly governor ball governor's
ball and global citizens yes lizzo did
all three and i think billy eyeless [ __ ]
all three i think she did too which is
just so crazy did they share a plane no
it's i was thinking the same thing i'm
like you really only have to go to one
of these festivals to see everything
yeah no it was wild to see like on my
instagram i'm like putting it together
i'm like okay but these two aren't
together and they're in a different
state right so if she had to drive on
her tour bus
taking six hours i thought the exact
same thing yeah it was a big weekend for
um festival season it was really nice
weather so i'm glad everyone had a good
time and thank you so much for bringing
that up because as i was walking over
here today you know how important i
think it is to acknowledge the space
that you're in right i do know and it's
been a while since we have done that and
i want to acknowledge a different type
of space today because i feel like after
summer
like the fall just like
it just goes so quickly like you're
never bleeding it's fleeting you never
acknowledge this transitional period
where it's like 60 degrees and like you
don't need a jacket but it's not hot and
it just comes and goes and it happens so
fast and i just feel like today is 64
degrees it's absolutely gorgeous outside
we need to acknowledge the space that
we're in take a moment
acknowledge the fall vibes the autumnal
vibes and just acknowledge it and be
grateful that we are here we're not in
the freezing winter we're not in this
weltering heat we're in the fall
acknowledge it you guys it's true it's
really true the weather is perfect and
the whole weekend it was gorgeous yeah
and it just makes life
a little bit sweeter worth living yeah
worth living theo says the same
to do how was your weekend it was
amazing theo had an amazing weekend
thank you so much for asking he spent so
much time with his best friend his dog
walker who theo's og dog walker is
probably like the love of theo's life
interesting and you know he's busy and
he's getting promoted and you know we're
we're so happy for him we still support
him but that does mean that theo gets
less time with him i mean on the
weekends he'll text me and be like you
know i'm
wanting to get some exercise like a theo
around i'm like of course he's around so
he got to spend saturday and sunday with
his boyfriend
and he's pooped he's like literally
daydreaming about him now that's so
sweet yeah
damn i mean brew had a crazy weekend did
i tell you what brew got into this
weekend oh no what my friends were over
and brew was you know entertaining
everyone making everyone laugh smile and
then i he was he left the room for a
while but zach was home so i just
figured they were
and then i just got like a funny feeling
it's been 20 minutes i'm like let me
just confirm that he's with zach and i
could not find him anywhere in the
apartment i was like this man
evaporated through the walls vanished
then i in
our guest bathroom the door was closed
so like i didn't think to look in there
but i was like you know sometimes he
gets in there and he closes the door
behind him i push it open the lights are
off he closed the door behind him and
that's where his big bag of food is and
we like your kids the food that we get
for him is like the size of those bags
from cheaper by the dozen yeah because
like that was the only one they had in
stock there's been a shortage of dog
food
added to the list yes and
he was in the bag of food he must have
eaten for 20 minutes straight oh my god
for the rest of the weekend even this
morning he like smells like the dog food
because he was a little bodybuilder
and we like tried to give him like
showers with strike i'm gonna give him a
proper bath today but he ate he must
have eaten so much belly get upset so
then
later that night we watched corella by
the way
we gave him some water and he threw up a
little bit which was good because he
needed to expunge some of this food then
the next few days made a couple of big
duties yeah and now brew is doing well
but okay it was like it was [ __ ]
crazy dogs do the craziest [ __ ] it was
so crazy close the door behind him in
there
that is the pure magic how does a door a
dog close the door
he just pushes it what did you think
about corella i thought it was great
so it was like it was a very chaotic
night for us because with brew and like
horses
we had to move from the living room to
the bedroom because of like his vomit um
and it took us forever to watch it but
we were enjoying it but i was like at
one point i was like i don't know if i'm
ever gonna finish this movie i know but
it was so good i
my only thing is like i still don't
understand
the rationalization how she turns into
like wanting to skin the dogs and wear
them because the dogs killed her no but
by the end like she's good with the dogs
and she's in control of it and she
realizes that
baroness
blew the whistle
you can't blame the pups no you can't
you really can't so i just don't think
they made that connection and you said
like i would feel like it was justified
why she became because they killed her
mother
yeah even though someone else was
blowing the whistle like the dogs did
push her mom off a cliff like i would be
upset too yeah i i mean how do you think
theo would feel if one of his friends
pushed me off a cliff to my face i think
he would skin them and wear them exactly
i think that's what he would do so did i
not say that you would understand no i
mean so that's just a little tenuous but
other than that it was fantastic like
one of the best movies i've seen in a
while a pleasure to watch
really on the money speaking of movies i
saw dear evan hansen oh do you really
want to hit us with this hot tape i went
to it it's not even a hot time i'm
kidding
i'm so clumped okay i went to the
theater and i had heard terrible things
about the movie and honestly i didn't
care like it was a friday night and i
wanted to go to the movies and i haven't
been able to do that and i live near a
theater that has those reclining chairs
and the snacks so me and ben were like
let's go and the theater was empty
literally because you select your seats
we saw there was two people in the
theater
so we went we got our food and you know
i was really enjoying the movie at first
because i had all my snacks and like my
favorite songs get played right at the
beginning right but then you ran out of
snacks and i ran out of songs and i was
forced to first of all there were so
many original songs which is such a
mistake
yeah such a mistake first of all
second of all i was really surprised i
didn't like it because first of all
there were so many people in the movie
who i like die for of course love ben
platt the girl who plays like the love
interest is the girl from book smart yes
i love her yeah i saw she reminds me of
kate baker from the disney channel days
sure real ones will know yes by the way
i love her and i think every movie she's
in i've never disliked and she was also
in that other show
that you watched that i didn't that was
like um was it about
i believe it was about a rape
oh my god she was incredible in that
it's called
unbelievable unbelievable on netflix
highly recommend okay yes so then also
you know who's in it plays the stepdad
is my favorite from law order svu the
guy who replaced stabler um i don't know
why i can't remember his name amy adams
is in it julianne moore is in it like
truly star-studded
but the movie
so i read something on the atlantic it
was like a really in-depth kind of
scathing review uh scathing sorry
and they made a really good point and i
think you'll hear this because you know
what the premise of the film is of
course
it's the same premise as the show and at
its core it's actually like a really
[ __ ] up
thing that evan hansen does but we're
supposed to like love this main
character and like feel for him when
actually what he did is like
unbelievably disgusting
so when it was all to like get into her
pants yeah like it was vile
so in a broadway show like there's just
so much going on the theatricality of it
like you're able to almost like look
past like that little thing in your
stomach that's like this is not a good
person yeah that's it and like when it's
you're watching a broadway show like
it's not really about the plot it's not
like what happens next no it's like
dancing i'm being entertained but in a
film it's much harder to ignore the fact
that like the crooks of the show is
actually like a really [ __ ] up premise
and it's so much more obvious on
the on the screen which i actually
really agreed with because i just found
myself like wanting to slap evan
and by the way i know there's so much
back and forth about like him being too
old and i like to pride myself on i
really don't see age like i've never
watched something and been like oh he's
too old or he's too young but they put
some like prosthetics on his face to
make him look younger that made him look
literally like he lived in a retirement
village like his face was just like
shiny and wrinkly i don't know what they
did in an attempt to make him look
younger but it made him look older
so i just left the theater about an hour
and a half through because i was like
this movie's fine but like i'm kind of
bored and we looked it up there was a
whole other hour left and i'm like it's
a friday night i've had a long week i
just want to be enjoying myself and
currently i've ran out of snacks i'm not
enjoying myself anymore and you didn't
feel like more snacks would help it no
because like actually the theater by my
house is rather small so like it's
limited options and we had already
gotten one of everything
so it wasn't had there wasn't anything i
didn't try yeah any standout items yes
dibs
you know those little kids crush it
every time the crunch flavor perfect
crunch bar so good yeah then i also had
popcorn and m ms and ben got nachos and
we had sodas and like that's really all
they had to offer delicious i made
popcorn while i watched cruella which
was also just torture with brew oh the
popcorn yeah by the way i know it's not
like on the approved list of things that
dogs like can or can't eat but every
time theo gets a
kernel that i drop on the floor he like
chokes for days don't let the you have
bruno have a popcorn when i have a
kernel i choke for days like i once had
a third kernel stuck in my teeth for
like a month and that's better than
having it stuck in your throat there's
actually i can't think of anything worse
to give a dog than popcorn you know like
he literally digests it the same way
that we do either gets caught in his
teeth or his gums it's insane he
actually sometimes throws up like if he
catches a kernel of my popcorn it's a
crazy it's a crazy snack i actually like
that has dawned on me before sometimes
i'm not having cucumber okay bro of
course but no
i also finished downton abbey
you did i did and i'm not gonna lie like
the sixth season i might try not to
spoil it because someone was like you
spoiled it for me so i'm gonna try and
just speak vaguely
the sixth season was like a little tired
and boring and i just feel like the
entire
premise was like what are we gonna do
this is not a spoiler like about the
hospital like something so who [ __ ]
cares and i was just like really kind of
itching for it to be over which sucks
because i loved the show in general this
sixth season was just like a little bit
of a letdown especially because like the
final two episodes were just centered
around a character who i personally
despise and only want bad things for
um that would be edith that would be
edith yes so
all in all such a fabulous show but you
know as
many shows like don't know how to land
the plane and i do believe that this was
one of them and i'm very much looking
forward to watching the movie at some
point the truckers for downtown are here
truckers for edith trucker's for edith
yes
so i'm gonna watch a movie
okay cool yeah the movie is like it's
fun to see everyone back together
it's beyond stupid okay um i just
thought the way that they ended it was
kind of funny and it felt kind of right
that edith the whole time
it's
one thing after one thing after another
this girl cannot catch a break and
you're living for it but by the end like
you do
feel bad for her and then the fact that
like she winds up out spoiler
outranking them all and living like this
wonderful life she has love she has
status like
i'm happy for edith she's been through a
lot and you know so let me just
everything she went through
does
negate what she did to mary what she did
to marry you well see i just wasn't
having that experience like by the end
i'm like just give her something i'm
like no let her keep i wasn't feeling
like just give her something but when
they gave her something i was like
i'll allow it you know what that's kind
of how life works sometimes i kind of
wanted like towards the end of like the
fifth season in the beginning of six i
kind of wanted mary and tom to be
together like i know like he used to be
married to her sister but she's dead
and like why not you know um it's like a
biblical thing they're writing their
cousins back in the day like it's a
biblical thing sure
but they're more like brother and sister
i don't i didn't see anything romantic
between the two of them mary would eat
him for breakfast like i just feel like
they could have they could have worked
it out like i was really here for him
there was no need there was no need for
them yes there was he already had a
child she already had a child true love
no maybe like sibby and
is i just thought what was interesting
is like there were so many characters
over the six seasons who came and went
and who they decided to like keep on for
all six seasons daisy like
i just couldn't believe like she was
worth
talking about you want to know something
crazy in real life at least last time i
checked you know the man days he ends up
with yeah he's dates edith in real life
oh that's cute
very cute yeah i like that
anyone else dating on the cast um that
was all that i remember oh i like that
yeah very good just an interesting
factoid so yeah it was a good balance
weekend went left house downton tings
i'm glad you had a nice balanced weekend
so did i for like you know uh pregnant
ladies weekend right i saw my friends um
i got a wax which like was productive i
had been putting it off yeah there's no
better feeling than walking out of there
a hundred percent it's like the end of
yom kippur like i'm as far away from a
wax as i'll ever be
and i feel like a champion i really do
we're proud of you we are
we have a big show today you guys
because some breaking news especially
that of tariq al musa
and we also have the real housewives of
salt lake city and potomac recap yeah
okay but we need to get into stuff we're
just like dilly dallying i just had a
productive weekend you know yeah and i'm
still reading jane eyre didn't read a
lot this weekend but reading before bed
so that you know i sleep better and it's
a really great book you know it's very
literary yes you know we're always
describing the leaves on the trees
at every turn yeah but jane is a great
gal she's a girly girl too gotta hang
with jade gotta hang with jane she's a
girly girl and she knows how to get down
oh also just wanted to say one really
random quick thing um
the points guy app launched today i saw
i've been using it for like a month
cause you know i'm friends with the
owner and it's the best thing ever like
you plug in all your credit cards all
your airlines it's really secure and
they will literally like aggregate all
your miles all your points for you oh
and you say hi i'd like to go to turks
and caicos the the interface is like
here's how you do it by spending thirty
dollars and thirty thousand points what
we've all needed what we've been waiting
for he's been talking about it for like
a really long time and it's like the
hardest thing to build but it's out
today for apple in the us so it's called
the points guy app and i highly
recommend it no that's [ __ ] brilliant
it's brilliant whenever i go somewhere
ever again literally that's how i'll be
traveling oh and then because i can't
understand my points for the life of me
but i think i have a lot one last thing
i'm really thinking about maybe going to
visit my sister who lives in florida
this weekend i don't know like
so their house is still under
construction and she like doesn't have a
bedroom for me that's the only thing
like i want to stay at a hotel i want to
stay with kayla and kayla's house okay
she said i could sleep on the couch
could you wait two weeks two weeks i
just have like things coming up like
literally i'm booked through november
like this is my most free weekend for a
while wow i've got weddings i've got
trips
look at you so should i go
to hotel well like definitely don't
i would i would
i would feel her out you know if you're
going to be she wants you to come she
wants you to come yeah and so and by the
way zach is leaving on saturday so i
would only have to sleep on the couch
for one night then i could live for
saturday but i don't know i just really
like i've been feeling like this hole in
my chest and it's about the size of a
kaler yeah no i i have the same size
hole and it gets bigger because she's
getting bigger she's getting bigger and
like i don't know i just feel like i'm
missing out on like her life precious
kayla time and i'm really feeling like i
i think the right thing to go to do is
to go do it i know right mm-hmm
i've olivia too obviously but like gotta
see kayla right but like you can
facetime with olivia like which i do
facetime with kayla but you can't get
not to talk [ __ ] but like she kind of
gives me nothing on facetime like she
never even acknowledges me she just like
looks no i'm like pulling teeth on
facetime and i get what i need oh i get
nothing because she has those eight big
teeth yeah and i'm pulling them but i
agree it's not like facetiming with a
girly girl no it's not at all and
olivia's a girly girl like she knows how
to face time kayla not so much she needs
to work on her skills well that would be
really fun for you i have plans this
weekend um what are you doing i'm going
on a trip with my friends where are you
going we're going to vermont oh that's
fun perfect
autumnal vibes and we're gonna do fall
tings are you gonna go apple picking and
such
that wasn't on the itinerary but
perhaps it will be but i was thinking
chili
chili chili you know
need not say it one more word chilly
okay now without further ado are you
ready to get into the fast life stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
today's episode is brought to you by
legacy box speaking of making memories
with ones that we love
are you holding on to boxes of old home
videos to share with friends and family
can you even watch that priceless
footage footage well legacy box is your
chance to have aging tapes films and
photos digitally preserved so the
ability to relive your family history is
never lost because of a leaky pipe or a
summer day that makes your attic hot and
melts your tapes and this week legacy
box is offering forty percent off at
legacybox.com toast so that you can
start future proofing your past today so
here's how it works their service is so
simple you use their kit to safely send
the moments you want preserved whether
that's you know tapes anything that you
have that you can really no longer use
their team will create a digital archive
by hand in the usa and then you'll
receive your new copies stored on the
cloud a thumb drive or a dvd along with
all the original media that you sent
them
with their tracking system you can
follow every step of the process so you
always know the originals are being
taken care of visit legacybox.com toast
to take advantage of this limited time
offer for 40 off take advantage of this
exclusive offer today and then use their
kit whenever you're ready that's
legacybox.com toast to save forty
percent off legacybox.com
thank you for that claudia it's a
pleasure
our first story
britney spears's fiancee sam ashkari is
speaking out saying that the
documentaries have left a bad aftertaste
for him sam ashkari hopes to get rid of
the bad aftertaste previous
documentaries about fiance britney
spears's ongoing conservatorship case
have left hours before the friday
premiere of
fx and hulu's controlling britney spears
the i mean uh the follow-up to the
emmy-nominated framing britney spears
the model slash actor shared his
thoughts on filmmakers dissecting her
struggles in the spotlight and
subsequent legal battle he said
apparently my opinion has increased
increased in value over the last few
days past docs left a bad aftertaste i'm
hopeful this one will be respectful i
don't blame cnn bbc or netflix which got
me through lockdowns for airing them
because as an actor i tell other people
stories too i question producers who
made them just to shed light without
input or approval from subject any
credit for light being shed should go to
hashtag free brittany by the way you
actually said something really similar
and poignant about all these free
britney documentaries when we were just
talking one day yeah like not on the
podcast you were basically like all of
these documentaries are really
highlighting like how evil the media was
to britney spears and how they're
responsible for so much of her anguish
and like mental health struggles and
also like the picture that was portrayed
of her that
you know affected other situations and
ultimately led to the situation she's in
now right
when literally why are we supposed to
believe any of these documentaries like
that are literally made by the media
like the framing britney spears is like
a new york times documentary in like the
new york times is the media right
they're like the media was so terrible
towards brittany it's like you're that
was you guys and that was like 10 years
ago and don't some of the people still
work with the office it wasn't that long
ago yeah so
it's like i actually really do hear what
he's saying yeah and i think that with i
never really thought about it i just
thought any you know
light being shed on her cause was
positive but like they are like getting
all these like ratings and all this
money money advertisers etc again
off her back you know it's a vicious
cycle and she has like nothing to do
with any of these things but like
everyone's talking about her and
me like right so i really should be paid
for
like i know it's a documentary and you
can make a documentary about anything
you want but like i don't know pay pay
the [ __ ] like she deserves it well i
mean maybe they would pay her if she
were in it
or at least like lending her expertise
and experience who knows better than
what's happening to britney spears than
britney spears yeah i just um i hadn't
really thought of it that way until he
said it yeah and i i agree with him no
and honestly at some point it's kind of
like overkill because how many
documentaries are going to say the same
thing like at first it's like yes give a
voice to the britney movement yes yes
yes second one even bigger better and
then by like the fourth or fifth
documentary that are really kind of
chronicling the same exact you know
thing that happened over the years again
the exploitation of britain now it's a
money grab like you're not here with
your peer intentions yeah yeah the
exploitation of britney spears so i'm
glad that he spoke up about it because
it made me think about it a little bit
differently and probably for other
people too
and
he
stating some facts
did he lie no he's speaking facts no and
honestly i'm just really glad that
britney spears has
samashkari in her corner i feel like
when they first started dating
you know everyone thinks
as they do with most successful women
like if he's not as successful he's like
a gold digger i don't know he has proven
to be hella supportive of britney spears
and really not back down as an ally to
brittany and what she's going through so
i'm here to say i respect samashari wow
love to see it yeah we do are you ready
for our next story it's a little fashion
news that kind of just like shook the
fashion world i'm kind of more of like a
maxinista than a fashionista so i don't
know if i'm really but i do think maxine
is going to appreciate this okay because
i'll let you know
it's about um an epic collab between
fendi and versace they dropped the
fendachi collaboration
um at fashion week fendi and versace
collaborated on this collection and it
is called
colloquially fendochi and the looks are
so [ __ ] sickening like it's actually
the best idea ever donatello versace
said it's a first in the history of
fashion
where two major designers had a true
creative dialogue that stems from
respect and friendship so it's between
donatella and kim jones offendee that's
actually such a good call like because
you know balenciaga louis vuitton
they're always doing collabs with like
the nba kiff like all these things and
like why don't they ever just collab
with each other i never thought about it
but like why not do you know fendi x
chanel like something like that yeah no
some of the so it's like the classic um
versace designs like on with f's on top
of it like it's extremely cool it is
really cool i like that idea i really
look forward to seeing dorie wear it
next season because like there was one
outfit that's just like
so dreamy
that i loved so much that only i think
darie will really wear could you see and
she'll do it head to toe there was like
a blind item going around i don't know
if it was from joomla or somewhere else
about like a certain housewife on the
west coast who's been
temporarily banned from shopping louis
vuitton just because
she buys so many things and returns
like a hundred percent of them
so obviously a lot of people thought it
was jerry because she's constantly head
to toe in lv
um
and a lot of her financials just some
like they just don't add up wait i
hadn't heard that i need a minute to
process
because she's always wearing louis
vuitton and even someone who's like
rockefeller it's like those are you
gotta diversify number those are like
four thousand dollar dress yeah at a
certain point it's just like bad
spending of course even though like we
live for the looks like i do really
question how every her [ __ ] underwear
literally louis vuitton the hair clip
the hair tie the necklace the shirt the
tights the shoes and the socks like
earrings every single day she's wearing
at least ten thousand dollars in louis
vuitton and it's almost always louis
vuitton that's like her designer of
choice so there was this blind item
going around that never confirmed that
it was to read or that it was even true
but once i heard it i'm like that makes
a lot of sense i just with when it came
to like to read and her expensive
wardrobe i just decided to start asking
questions you know ignorance is bliss
right but then you hear something like
that and
it adds up doesn't it it does
wow i know so again not confirming or
denying just a conspiracy theory that
i'm now fully subscribed to
interesting and as far as just like
fashion things i mean fashion week has
been like going on around the world for
a few weeks now and like this was the
first thing that i saw that i was like
ooh it's titillating the first thing
that i saw and is now just kind of
cementing that like versace is really
out here doing the absolute most they
had addison ray at their show in paris
or milan i forget she was looking so
adorable and i'm just so happy for her
and i just love her and i just hope
she's feeling good about herself no i
know
she her look was everything the whole
lot like everything that's so cute in
milan was so cute and really had me
feeling excited about fashion tings
right and now versace is out here making
historic collabs and i just think like
justice for versace like doing the most
also house of gucci comes out soon yeah
i may not be ethical but i am fair
is that from house of gucci it's from
the trailer and it went viral on tick
tock i was gonna say like do you
memorize the trailer no it's like people
like when they do like really [ __ ] up
things then they make a tick tock i may
not be ethical and then she like she's
stirring her espresso is that lady gaga
she's stirring her espresso she's like i
may not be ethical
but i am fair
she looks good in it like the commercial
trailer played in the ben platt theater
before and i actually wish i was seeing
that like it looks so good really okay
we'll have to see it that'll be exciting
i love going to the theater
yes or as they call it in downton abbey
the kinema they say canada yes
i was shook when they said that thank
god for the subtitles because i
literally would not know what the hell
these people are saying
kinema that's like a cinema
by the way i need to update everyone on
my outlander journey because i'm in a
really good place and i need to share
with everyone happened because all of
season one i had so first of all the
show was very you know brutal and i was
having anxiety leading up to the season
finale and claudia had watched it and i
didn't know what i was gonna do because
like i'm if i'm gonna watch the show i
need to know what happens
anyways i went all the way up to the
episode i knew what was like you know
jamie was in a certain situation that i
figured wouldn't end well i didn't want
to watch the specifics you told me the
specifics and i fast forwarded into the
middle of the episode and continued
watching from there there were
definitely flashbacks i definitely got
like but i didn't i never had to like
watch the prolonged scenes
and then i made it to season two which
is a much happier season they're in
seven france 1745 it's extremely
fabulous you know like pre-revolutionary
marie antoinette
vibes and it was a fun place to be now
they're back in scotland oh spoiler
alert um but i'm really glad that i
stuck with it and then
so i was feeling good like i was feeling
like looking forward to watching more
episodes fabulous yeah are you ready for
our next story
sure about fabulous people doing
fabulous things
kaya gerber and jacob alordy make their
red carpet debut at the academy museum
of motion pictures opening gala
just looks so sickening this event looks
so sickening i don't know what the
academy museum of motion pictures
opening gala in the la is no clue but
they you know they put on a nice affair
and what a guest list what a guest list
what a wardrobe budget katy perry was
there lady gaga was there olivia rodrigo
was there
um halle berry jennifer hudson tiffany
haddish adriana lima regina hall
gabrielle union dwayne raid no it was
pretty star started i was seeing
pictures all over the gram and i was
like damn this is a party i would have
loved to have been invited to and when
you look at the pictures it really looks
like it could be like canned yes i
thought it was for sure like you know
one of those obscure film festivals
right and it's just right here in l.a so
fabulous yeah um i think a lot of you
know the talk is about olivia rodrigo
because she wore quite a revealing dress
and she looked absolutely
s
show stopping what are the people saying
just like that she looks so great groups
or that did you see your boobs of course
it was just like booby booby booby were
they saying it like
that was too much boo well there was
just karen's being like wow really
sexualizing herself like so don't look
at it you're a freak for you're
sexualizing her um i mean
the titties are a sexy dress it was a
sexy dress for sure i happened to think
it was everything of the sort and
honestly i feel like i've seen that
dress before like i think kim and
kourtney kardashian have both worn it
interesting i just want to look up her
age because i just continually think of
olivia rodriguez 16 because like that's
when her story really began
with john
and like that has played a large role in
her narrative because like they couldn't
be public because she was 16 so yeah
she's always 16 to me so first of all
you're all to be wearing that dress i
you know of course she's 18. okay but
also like sabrina carpenter not to keep
pitting women against other women but it
just says something interesting to know
here she goes
so serena carpenter walked in the savage
x fenty show she looked unbelievably
gorgeous and sexy and now i just kind of
feel like her and olivia are doing like
sexy offs like oh really i can one up
your sexiness i see your lingerie i
raise you a very revealing dress like
they're just going back and forth okay i
saw sabrina carpenter's sexiness and i
thought it was really great and
then i didn't think that when i saw this
because also like these loops take like
weeks to i'm just sorry to come up with
she doesn't just like go shop off the
rack and show up that night like you
like not like like us
like you
yeah like us like whenever you have an
event you're like i need to go get a
dress that's not olivia rodrigo
okay i'm just saying it does feel like
you know there's a conversation being
had
amongst the publicists about who could
be sexier exactly okay i mean i love a
little publicist like drama publicist
drama this event was just fabulous and
honestly kaia gerber and jacob lord he's
like talk about two people who are just
so effortlessly gorgeous like
it's actually not fair no it's not fair
and like when you look at these pictures
they look like they could have been
taken in 2021 in
1990 yeah 1950 like their old hollywood
glamour timeless
beautiful yeah and even the outfits are
you know they're not necessarily so
modern they're classic like very
if this is a beautiful couple and you
know what shame on anna wintour because
this could have been her moment at the
met gala if she invited jacob belordy
100
and you know because it's just because
he wasn't invited because he was in new
york he went to the after parties like
oh he did yeah he wasn't invited then he
wasn't there well to be honest like i
really cannot look at this couple
without just thinking about joey king
like i really can't
it didn't even cross my mind really
i just feel like he moved on from her so
fast
and ended up in like this fabulous
a-list relationship like his
relationship with joey king was like a
middle school relationship and now he's
like in high school with his like adult
girlfriend that's how i feel his
relationship with joey king was a was a
high school relationship and now he's in
college yeah like his college girlfriend
and everyone's just obsessed they're so
a-list and like i don't know it just
must be tough for joey king i
because i didn't like watch all the
movies i i guess that's like not what i
think of jacob lordy so much as and
it didn't cross my mind but yeah no if
i'm
if i'm his ex and i'm seeing these pics
i'm
vomiting
vomiting yeah yeah are you ready for our
next story only if it's the next story
that's brought to you by public wreck it
is how funny you've got to check out
public wreck they make athleisure in
waist and in seam sizes because they
believe that comfort starts with a
better fit so they're really at public
rec focused on sizing that makes sense
their all-day jogger is a first of its
kind technical pant available in waist
and in seam sizes it means women can
shop based on their unique proportions
no more settling for small medium or
large it's actually like the most
detailed sizing i've ever done on
leggings or even any pants in general
especially because i'm a wide gal and a
short gal and i find so many times
things are so long on me but at public
wreck you can actually measure the
length of your pants so that you're not
stuck with like pants that literally go
past your toes it's so stupid
they also have the best waistband on
earth it's super thick high rise no roll
waistband it'll keep you comfortable all
day long they've spent years engineering
the perfect blend of softness stretch
and durability and it's all the
performance benefits you love with the
added style for more formal occasions um
it's just fabulous it's really like
getting pants made for you at a tailor
it's very specific
they're designed to last a lifetime
they're designed for you and it's just a
fabulous place to shop if you want to
feel seen if you don't then can't relate
we've never had pants that fits so well
it is game changing and they rarely
offer discounts at public wreck but
right now they have an exclusive offer
just for the morning toast listeners go
to publicrec.com
and use code toast to receive 10 off
that's public rec rec public rec dot com
use the promo code toast for 10
off thank you for that claudia our next
story is a little happy couple news is a
pleasure summer house stars kyle cook
and amanda are married they tied the
knot on saturday at her family's new
jersey home oh that's cute i was
wondering where it was a source said it
was an emotional and beautiful ceremony
and of course it was studded with their
guests
and castmates carl lindsey danielle
paige luke and sierra and also craig
connor and austin kroll were there
because they're winter house cast mates
and also
paige and craig posted two photos
together from the photo booth so for me
that was like my biggest takeaway from
the evening is that i think everybody
like no i mean happy couple beautiful
weddings of course of course i follow
paige on instagram and i was like
blacked out because it was saturday
night after the concert and i like
tapped and i was like oh my god i cannot
believe paige distorber put me on her
close friends story that's what i
thought i'm like oh my god no she posted
this publicly
they are such a good looking couple and
i just want to say
i mean it's hard for me because i
actually really like love naomi and
craig and like part of me just like
really thinks they're otp but i think
this is such a good match like for a
million different reasons and i'm
obsessed yeah i there's been a lot of
speculation about whether or not they
were dating and then like it came out
that they hardcore were not dating i do
think they're under contract to not
share that they fell in love on winter
house and so that's supposed to be like
a surprise for the fans so i don't know
if this was like a slip that she posted
this or i mean he was at this
this is not a confirmation you never
necessarily have to be a couple it's not
like they're kissing but they're
probably a couple and it's a beautiful
beautiful couple and i agree like naomi
and craig but there there's no way back
for them they're literally like two
ships passing in the night there's just
no way back yeah
well i just have to say like one of the
many great things to come out of this
quarantine was like me getting into
summer house and i'm like now so excited
to watch like i believe that they filmed
obviously
for bravo like kyle would never let his
wedding go i felt like cameras so that
and then we also have winter house so
like i don't know i'm just really
looking forward to lots of premium
content obviously if you watch summer
house then you know
hannah was not there which is like a big
deal and just kind of like the official
break
i don't watch summer house but also like
aren't amanda and hannah like enemies
well so like they're like good friends
and kyle and hannah this is what
happened the whole season okay kyle and
hannah just like cannot get on the same
page and it left amanda like in this
terrible position and eventually she
just had to choose her husband over her
friend who like wouldn't get along with
her husband and honestly both hannah and
kyle were equally as responsible like
going at each other but for amanda she
was like i need to choose her inner
peace which of course i respect yeah um
oh okay and they were just like going
non-stop and then
you know like everyone fights on shows
like that so you think whatever like
they're all still friends but like no it
was an official breakup and then hannah
left the show and now she's not invited
to the wedding like it's an official
it's over got it well if like someone
was fighting with your husband all the
time like they wouldn't be at your
wedding no
no no
even though like if someone was arguing
with ben i'd probably be like well what
did he do you know
yeah i'm like yeah i'm like no i can
feel that
but yeah no honestly the only thing that
bothered me was
when kyle was just going on about how
hannah doesn't work because she's a
podcaster i'm like i'm like kyle watch
your mouth yeah no that's those are
fighting words fighting [ __ ] words
are you ready for our fifth and final
story
yeah i think it's you know it's been a
few days but
it's time for the final story
[Music]
he's got celiac's disease
[Applause]
he has to stay away from
bread
i'm so sorry to let you know that's not
the final story i'm gonna keep
referencing tarik i'm gonna say he has
breaking news did you not hear no he's
been diagnosed with celiac disease i saw
i saw that i did um i just didn't know
if you wanted to add it to the segment
of tarik's mindless news okay well let
me just say it's mindless news but i
don't want to insult anyone who has
celiac disease like i know it's a very
real issue that you have to struggle
with but my god the way that they're
reporting on it with this picture of
heather and tarik in a doctor's office
holding
like he's just been told he has 36 hours
to live like it's so [ __ ] dramatic
and it's like okay you just can't eat
bread or you get like a belly ache like
it's not it's not life or death yeah
but our fifth and final story is not
it's not it's like completely unrelated
maybe you know maybe i should have
decided to speak about targets i'm sorry
like before we started the show i
thought we were like an agreement that
we were going to talk about no i said
that we couldn't bring it up because it
was too painful for do so why haven't
you stopped me when i've literally been
referencing it for the last hour during
the show
okay but people are probably so confused
okay so let's do like a story for a mini
yeah well that's it he was diagnosed
with celiacs and heather's there for
them him a hundred percent and we made
sure that people magazine made sure that
we knew that heather is going to be
there for him through thick and thin you
know honestly it has not been a good
like week and a half for tariq he got
coveted yeah and he got celiacs yeah but
the picture i mean i haven't read the
articles intensely but like was it
something that was filmed this diagnosis
there was like a little hgtv like emblem
in the corner of the picture
months ago i'm thinking it's it's been
filmed yeah they're so [ __ ] dramatic
it's crazy like it was a people
exclusive that he has celiac's disease
yeah yeah that's like me literally
partnering with vogue to let everyone
know like i'm allergic to peanuts
it's so moronic that is but again no
shade to the celiac community like it is
a real struggle it's just like the
narrative around tarek was a little
dramatic okay i think that's fair our
fifth and final story is just some fun
content content news because netflix is
to presentation oh right
it was like their you know netflix con
okay but they like shared when
everything is dropping what's getting
season twos some trailers like they
shared it all so i'm gonna share what we
care about i saw something for
bridgerton we got a trailer for
bridgerton the crown is coming back in
november 2022.
so a whole year see you never yeah
that's [ __ ] anything about the
society season two in there no and
that's [ __ ] that's disgusting
stranger things i know people are into
that will won't return until sometime in
2022 but they they gave a clip you know
what you're right i saw all of this like
on social media like and i was like
there's so much netflix news but now i
know because
there's a kanye documentary coming to
netflix in case you were craving more
kanye the first of its three-part
documentary series about the prolific
rapper will premiere next year i just
love celebrity documentaries like i i
could do a whole podcast series on yeah
and he has like footage i mean i think
he's been
so
there's gonna be so much good stuff
there sex education you ever watch um
you know i started it and like honestly
all the characters were like annoying
the [ __ ] out of me so i just stopped got
a fourth season
sex life got a season two
oh god well it did end on a cliffhanger
so i assumed that and it was like the
number one show on earth um bridgerton
they dropped a trailer it will be back
next year but we got to see you know
it's about the older brother anthony
bridgeton and then we got to see his new
leading lady
and i saw her a scene from the two of
them
then other shows too that we don't watch
obviously we talked about tiger king
season two between you and i but not on
the show they have got to stop like for
real yeah like the tiger king jokes are
no longer like giving me life honestly
they never really did yeah murder
mystery is getting a sequel that movie
with adam sandler and jennifer aniston
and i kind of like the movie i will
watch the sequel i heard the movie was
pretty good actually it was cute um
emily in paris is coming
back
at christmas honestly i'm kind of here
for it like december 22nd i kind of
missed that chaotic time when we were
all just like collectively making fun of
emily and the things she was doing in
paris i honestly don't know if i'll
watch no come on it's so funny no but
like
i really have to make a conscious effort
to like not spend time watching stuff
that i don't like and that doesn't serve
me you have to but i also have to do a
job sure so like if you were to say to
me everybody the whole toaster community
is waiting for your view of emily and
paris they will be by the day and if i
feel that sort of
energy
i will do my duty
duty
jew t
but
you know absent of that i wouldn't watch
it
okay fine i mean it was it was
everything of the sword in the most
nothing of the sort way if you know what
i'm saying i do know what you're saying
i just also have to say that
one of the great joys of my life has
been watching downton abbey and
literally seeing how much they say
nothing of the sort because that's like
an old-timey way of speaking i will do
nothing of the salt yeah and i'm like no
i will do nothing of the sword yeah it
was everything of the sort that's what
i'm saying
um so those are the fastest stories feel
as though you needed to know them
definitely and it's not over yet because
we've got two that juicy recaps for you
with the real houses of potomac and the
real houses of salt lake city let's
start with the real housewives of
potomac because that event that giselle
had the audacity to host
was really one of the great joys of my
life there was so much to unpack there
was so much to unpack why does gizelle
even put herself into those positions
like
ripe for the picking because not only
it's what okay you can't control your
house is under control that's fine but
first of all they were doing
construction as the event was going on
the people were running over these two
by fours like it was twisted she was
sitting literally in a parking lot with
like these balloons it was just so low
budget it really was and you know how
much these women like with with this
particular group of women because none
of them are really like good genuine
friends like they're always being shady
towards each other if you're throwing an
event like it has to be tip top and it
was not especially since like your home
has been the source of people making
jobs like why would you invite people
over when there's construction and all
these things and they can't even go
inside the house and there's a stairway
outside that leads to nowhere well i'm
actually so glad you asked because you
know what we've learned over the last
couple years is that giselle bryant has
not one ounce of taste or style so it's
actually very possible that she was like
proud of the way her home looked and
that's why she wanted to invite the
women or that's the only thing i can
think of because
why didn't
okay i'm sure i heart radio paid for
like the the ven like the setup and
everything pay for a restaurant do it at
a restaurant 100 i don't think it's that
she thought it looked good i really
don't i'm just throwing it out there as
a possibility i think it's that she um
is so not self-aware that she couldn't
even think like this might reflect
poorly on me like she thinks everything
she does is like so fabulous like that
there's no holes and because i mean if
she thought that there were the visible
holes in her stories like that we see
she wouldn't go after people the way
that she does because it's just like
glaringly obvious
yeah
so there's there was quite a few
arguments under the tent the first that
i want to ask your opinions on is
candace and mia
okay the thing is is like i do feel like
mia
sorry i just like asked her opinion and
then spoke over you but
um mia like definitely crossed a line
like just i i don't i didn't agree with
how she was acting i don't think she
acted out of bad intent but i just
wouldn't do that but my god like candace
just [ __ ] takes things to the next
level like your mother's low budget
she's like out of control
mia was making a lot of sense to me i
showed up to this low budget i don't
know i don't want to say it there i
showed them to a parking lot yep there
was no one here a parking lot with no
cars so i'm asking your mom who's your
manager and is he getting paid because
guess what you get what you pay for i
think that because they were put in such
a bad situation yeah like that was
poorly run poorly run she's allowed to
ask questions about like she's here
doing a favor she's allowed to ask
questions when she framed it like that i
was like yeah no it's still probably
shady and maybe you know mother teresa
wouldn't act that way but like
if you want people to drive out of their
way
have a mat have things managed yeah i
don't disagree with craft services yeah
it was it was messy and just like the
thing is
i would probably not ask those questions
but i would be more like giselle like i
would never ask but i'm curious and what
the answer was yeah and i think candace
is obviously candace is going to take
this really like defensively like this
was her project and it was embarrassing
right but like it's being called a
budget because it was low budget and all
the but i watched the music video so did
i all of the budget went into the other
scenarios yeah like they had a setting
at a diner where they ordered water and
there was already water on the table um
they went to that garage auto body shop
and they had those scenes there and
there was i saw a budget elsewhere me
too and then in the final scene i saw a
parking lot yeah so not only was the
budget she told us was ten thousand
dollars all those ten thousand dollars
went to scenes that the women were not
in
mia showed up to zero dollars yeah and
so even though calling her music video
low budget is shady
she was speaking facts yeah no and
really like i'm just really kind of done
with candace going so below the belt
that's not a for me that's not a fair
way to fight and two it's just like who
wants to be friends with someone where
every time we have an altercation that
she calls ashley fat she calls uh your
mom's low budget like she just always is
crossing the line and i just personally
cannot get behind that i cannot yeah and
so between mia and wendy
because wendy and candace really have
each other's backs yes they do it's like
they're on different teams on the show
like they always have each other's backs
i wendy was just like so all over the
place at the party and really
indefensible and it's just like
um
in certain situations this season she's
really been someone that you like want
to champion and then she's really cringe
but then she's so cringe and she's so
just
unnecessarily out of line like even
inviting the girls to the trip if it's a
trip with partners you don't have to say
anything right not like you'll bring
your luggage which is a joke she made
twice right you just have to say i'm
inviting everyone on a trip bring your
husbands and that's insult enough right
to have to say you and
he's coming eddie yeah michael not one
yeah luggage literally
it's it's overkill and then you become
the villain whereas you could have just
had a reasonably shady moment
love the synergy also
the episode was frustrating because i
just it was like giselle's party and
gizelle was in charge but like giselle
was basically throwing out these prompts
and was like would you find it
reasonable or would you find a shady for
someone to do x and she was like
basically calling out what
karen did like to apologize and make up
with someone and then also still be
holding a grudge when literally her and
karen made up and then she sits down at
the party and says karen you can't use
the bathroom and so she's wendy she's in
the top of the episode in her personal
scene she was like i guess i made up
with these girls but i'm not over it and
they can't use my bathroom so like
literally you're trying to make fun of
karen when literally you pot kettle
black like you literally just did that
to two people also when they flash back
to everything all the beef between karen
and giselle over the years it's like
what she said about rey's
grave is like the least of it the least
erica lyles like i completely forgot
like it's so much deeper it's so much
deeper and i just [ __ ] love karen and
honestly i will have absolutely no karen
slander when it pertains to the candles
because robin was like oh she probably
heard wendy was doing a candle and just
like came up with a candle out of her
ass which is first of all not how it
works
wendy doesn't even have a business she
made a couple candles and is like
has five of them where karen's ready for
retail like do you not come for karen
and karen's a perfume air like this is
karen's a natural next step and i am
curious is what big box retailers are
carrying it because i would very much
like that candle in my home it's
gorgeous yeah three wicks
and you know what i like that she went
over to wendy's house and was like you
know what there's space enough there's
more than enough space for both of us in
the candle space like you and i
we're not gonna be and you know what i
love that that's what ramona singer
likes to call women supporting other
women yeah i agree i do think that
karen always planned to have a candle
she heard when he was coming out the
candle they're on the same show they're
using the same platform oh i need to get
my candle out there's nothing no
fearless there's nothing nefarious
nothing embarrassing there's nothing in
the fairies about harry huger period i
agree and honestly like gotta start
calling more people heifers like i don't
know what it means but i just feel like
you're a heifer like i think it means
does it mean like that well it i think
the literal term is pig cow
okay i mean just funny like i'm sorry it
was like i got backstage so i could be
here with you heffa's a heifer is a
young female cow that has not borne a
calf
that has not given birth yet i just
don't want him it's a cow i don't want
to be good calling people fat like if
anyone call me a cow i'd actually jump
off a roof no but like you know how in
maybe even in downtown like in the uk
like they will call oh she's a cow like
but it as it's like not it's not a okay
for me it's not a a it's a weight a size
thing it's like a personality thing for
me so maybe that's like in now in
america it's a heifer um all i'm saying
is for me like don't [ __ ] call me a
cow like i'll kill you can i call you a
heather
yeah there's something endearing about
it like i kind of am obsessed with
heifer it's a great word and i just
wouldn't like to understand like how to
use it more colloquially and like what
the meaning is behind it so i'm not out
here like offending oh you know what so
the text like
dictionary merriam-webster says a young
cath mellon webster defines stalker when
claudia calls me when she facetimes me
like three times in 10 minutes i pick up
and i say miriam webster defines stalker
for me
and then we laugh it's just like it's
just good sister times good sister time
gst okay
urban dictionary heifer
a prodigiously large female
[ __ ] yeah
a heavier fat woman
you know what
you know i'm kind of like on this
mission to change the stigma behind the
word [ __ ]
yeah i'm also going to be destigmatizing
heifer on my way to justice apparently
it means a pregnant cow am i a heifer
you are i'm so jealous
okay now let's dive into the salt lake
city recap where we get sat on that like
oh are you you have something else to
say keep going i don't know there was
just like so much going on go for it i
like i need to you know
love um ascala
yeah really felt like she should have
been given a full-time role because she
is
she's doing the opposite of what wendy
did wendy came in last season was kind
of boring just because she just followed
whatever candice did which is so
uninteresting like have your own
opinions ascala is on opposite sides of
robin when she's here is
i forget that like robin brought her in
me too because like they're so i never
even see them talk to each other yeah
and i love this friendship between
ascala wendy and karen i do
me too like supporting the teachers
love to see it okay i guess i don't have
anything more to say like those were the
big ticket items yeah
well the
salt lake city recap is brought to you
by pendulum there's so much more to
nutrition than calories your diet plays
a huge role in your microbiome which in
turn impacts your mental and physical
well-being a healthy gut microbone is
key to a healthy lifestyle we're all now
learning about the connection between
gut microbiome health and type 2
diabetes and the pendulum glucose
control is the first and only medical
probiotic that's designed to manage a1c
and blood glucose levels through the
health of your
microbiome from those with type 2
diabetes diet and exercise alone are
often not enough to management and the
best approach to emphasize diet exercise
and a healthy gut microbiome the
connection has been widely recognized by
leading scientists who are studying
diabetes pendulum's team of scientists
doctors and innovators isolated the
unique strains of beneficial gut
bacteria that help people with type 2
diabetes manage their blood sugar levels
they've isolated one keystone strain
that is now available to pershing
purchase pendulum is the only place to
find this highly sought after strain
formulated and bottled in the u.s with
the highest safety and quality standards
non-gmo project verified take control of
your glucose levels today try pendulum
glucose control for for 90 days and if
you're not satisfied with your levels
you'll get your money back so visit
pendulum life to find out more and use
the promo code tmt for 20 off your first
bottle of membership so that's
p-e-n-d-u-l-u-m life.com
pendulumlife.com promo code tmt thank
you for that claudia it's a pleasure
okay so salt lake city i would say you
know content
if i if i'm rating it out of five stars
like it was two and a half on the
content level
the visual level
was ten stars i wouldn't say two and a
half i didn't think it was so bad
because like they didn't trouble us with
so much torturous like personal scenes
most of the episode they were at the fly
fishing so at least like the women were
together talking about something yeah
mary farted on brooks like it was such a
bizarre episode like mary oh but mary
wasn't at fly fishing right no mary
doesn't go to things that she doesn't
want to go to no she and she also
doesn't get invited to like half the
things that go on because jen cha's like
always the one throwing parties and
to jen shot mary cosby does not exist
but i believe jen invited mary okay to
this there's like a weird thing where
like there's like this group of women on
the housewives and and mary i'm telling
you like 90 of the time is not there no
i know she wasn't in vegas but you know
what like i think once jen you know is
behind bars like mary's coming out no
and like mary's planning the girls trips
yeah so it is really weird it is but
like i also respect that like mary will
not associate with someone who like had
was treated her so poorly yeah and you
know because all these women have like
put all this terrible [ __ ] behind them
like even with meredith and jen like i
rea and it doesn't seem like they ever
get over it but like in real life like
you don't get over your friend doing all
of these things to your child and yes
there's so many comments brooks is not a
child he's 22 years old but he's
meredith's kid like
40 years old and they're 80 arguing
meredith's kid agreed and to be honest
like i do feel like meredith was acting
like very erratically but like how
frustrating to like literally have facts
like to know that this particular person
is
saying things about your child liking
things on social media that are of a
homophobic nature when you of course
just feel so protective of your child
and of course when it pertains to a
sexuality he hasn't even spoken about it
like you just want to protect him so you
know all of this to be fact like you
live in the real world with fact-based
database questions
and you finally
get the nerve to con confront this
person and the thing they have to say is
like delusional it wasn't me i don't uh
i don't know what you're talking about i
don't run my own social media i would
have reacted the same way too like
and that's exactly what she said she's
like jenna's like what are you talking
about i'm talking about reality like you
jen shaw live in your own world where
everyone is against you and you don't do
anything to hurt anyone and like you're
the victim in all this with an actual
victim which is meredith and her family
i i would have exploded as well honestly
like so frustrating to just talk to
someone who's so delusional and devoid
of any sort of realistic nature
i had no issue with meredith's reaction
i would have reacted in the exact same
way and she also like
explained herself and and her pov so
well and it's like anything other than
i'm sorry is unacceptable yep and i mean
i guess it was enough for heather so jen
might have thought it was enough for
meredith just to say that wasn't me no
because heather is a pushover who's so
desperate to be friends with jen that
jen can get away with these like fake
ass not lie lies apologies filled with
lies but meredith is a strong [ __ ]
woman yeah and she also is like
she would probably forgive jen if she
received an apology that was so deep and
heartfelt and sincere but she's not even
getting a i'm sorry a shitty apology
she's getting nothing she has to leave i
totally respect that and honestly [ __ ]
lisa barlow and [ __ ] jenny too i was
just about to say i really didn't like
jenny um getting involved i didn't like
her getting involved but like
at first when she jumped in i was i was
like okay with you know there needs to
be some mediation order we need we need
an order in the court and she was
ordering the corner bringing like strong
energy but she said in her confessional
that she doesn't agree with the way that
meredith handles things which is like
just to ice people out i disagree with
me too with jenny about that i think
there are lines that people have in life
and when boundaries when you've crossed
that line like the expectation that you
are forgiven is
is not no longer where you can be
forgiven but like the relationship is
tainted it always will be you cannot go
back from certain things completely
agree i was so disappointed in jenny
because up until then i really liked her
and honestly this has absolutely nothing
to do with you so for you to butt in
with the worst take of all time that was
just really brave of you jenny like
really brave no and with so much energy
and like i keep saying this like all the
new girls come in they bring all of this
energy into whatever conflict they they
choose and it's always the wrong
conflict always and i'm like always the
wrong energy
i'm like but i but i do look forward to
seeing that energy elsewhere right and
then
yeah
mia mia
crystal but it seems like mia brings it
next week next week with cancer on
potomac yeah so jen crystal yeah jenny i
like that you have a fighting spirit i
look forward to seeing you bring it to
maybe when jen shaw is um arrested
arrested and taking advantage of you
know the most vulnerable people no i
love the fighting energy but like
channel your energy in more positive
ways like because you were just so wrong
like i'm sorry there was literally
nothing wrong with meredith and honestly
the fact that everyone was like so
outraged by her and like you know
meredith calm down come back like
they're gaslighting her because meredith
is a hundred percent entitled to feel
angry that her son is being dragged by a
grown woman yes i know he's 22 he's
still her son who's struggling with
something like his sexuality and jen is
out here
jen is out here accusing heather of
being racist with n with literally no
like um
proof and then she's out here being like
dead ass homophobic like
and and saying that wasn't me and saying
i don't know what you're talking about
it's i actually really can't no and then
jen like turns it into like she's the
victim what about my family what about
your family that was i'm sorry that was
crazy and then when meredith finally
left and jen's like why am i i the
reason where everybo all the problems in
the world it's like i literally i can't
deal with people who are textbook
villains yeah and then find a way to
make themselves the victim mentality at
least if you're gonna be a villain and
you're gonna be mean and you're gonna
talk [ __ ]
own it
you can't also be the victim no it's a
crazy thing and it drives people who are
arguing with you it drives them crazy
look at meredith like it's it's so
devoid of reality yeah it's probably
infuriating and honestly now i kind of
understand with heather like if you
actually really want to go tip toe for
toe like you're not speaking to someone
who
lives on this planet so like honestly if
you just want to fix things with jen
like just [ __ ] you have to forget
about everything because you're never
going to get to a place right but like
the only reason to do that is like if
the other stuff with jen and the
friendship is like you know worth
salvaging there's you know she seems
like a fun friend and yeah like heather
sees value in their friendship right i
think for meredith nothing would ever be
more valuable than you know her son her
son so i understand where she's coming
from i probably would have reacted the
same way
i really don't like this narrative that
meredith doesn't have good style like i
know she wears a lot of blazers but i
think she's amazing style no i think i
mean
like marriage that's coming from mary
when mary was saying and i was like mary
why do you have to be shady towards
everyone no and also like i understand
shadiness like when it's appropriate
like meredith has amazing style no but
not from mary's point of view but i'm if
i'm sure if you asked meredith about
mary's style cuckoo and while she's
sitting there in like her hat like right
it's just about you know who you're
talking to i think meredith has a great
style i think she's so consistent and
classy me too and there's nothing
there's nothing negative you could say
yeah you know it's nothing like it's not
groundbreaking every single look but
like it's sophisticated she knows what
looks good on her and she like she has
her sticks with it yeah i like that in
personal style
so um
all in all it was a good episode and it
was just gorgeous like gotta go bike
skiing yeah whatever that was oh yeah
there we got like so many good ski
scenes it was like making me so
like rdh for like snow and weather it
was just so stunning i also need like
whitney and heather to make up with lisa
because that's just like a
no i don't care conflict that i have no
time for no i i think they actually like
lisa these days no i actually don't like
lisa and i like whitney obsessed with
whitney yeah i need whitney heather and
meredith to like via crew i think they
are and then they have that lunch with
mary oh yeah throw in mary too love mary
love mary i like jenny too i love her
kids when they spend their saturday they
do science projects every saturday i was
just felling her husband's a little
annoying yeah no the stuff with the kids
was like stuff so wrong stop i think
would you say she had nine miscarriages
leave the woman alone i think he'll
probably watch that and maybe change his
tune plus she would have to get surgery
to even
begin the pro i mean hsc it's enough
they have three kids they have yeah it's
enough but like i just hope one day my
kids want to spend every saturday doing
science projects no they're like really
cute and then they all cleaned up the
kitchen
and like
happily they were like
having fun with rashes
like that her daughter who's the cutest
camper she's pretentious camper yeah
she's just so [ __ ] cute yeah
and they are a pleasure to watch yeah
except her husband was really starting
to bother no no yeah like so it's not
all like it's not all
but like they obviously you know have a
really nice family life yeah and just
spending saturdays doing science
projects it's like all you could want
for the campus it's so cute it's so cute
um so that was salt lake city and that
was our show that was our show
that's all we got for you guys and i
hope it was enough i felt i felt like it
was strong i do feel like
that the chips fall where they may thank
you so much for listening to the morning
toast milani morning show where we
deliver the fast fast stories that you
need to know every monday through friday
on youtube so if you're watching this on
youtube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available as podcasts and we're
podcasting we found out spotify itunes
stitcher public radio i already kept
blocking all the places we're listening
to the podcast finals morning till
evening five star reviews stunning and
smart we are and if you made it to the
end of this episode congratulations you
have made it to the society season two
and if you
want to let us know that you are still
here still listening to the episode
being a true toaster please in honor of
tariq al musa go drop a piece of bread
the emoji of a piece of bread on our
most recent instagram just to kind of
show tariq what he can't have and no and
just show your support for target we're
standing in solidarity with target emily
so during this very difficult time thank
you guys so much have an amazing day and
we'll see you tomorrow
bye
you